why are shares still available so i got
a question from one of my youtube
viewers love you guys hussein who wrote
in to say dear reverend thank you for
all the help i appreciate if you could
include the answer to this question as
well this may look stupid but can you
elaborate how come company shares are
still available after all these years of
selling on the nasdaq new york stock
exchange many of the shares are already
acquired by the owners founder ceos and
so on and they may run for people to buy
for so long
how come there are still shares
available
so this might be a basic question but
it's not a stupid question hey if you
have questions you got to get answers
you want to be able to make decisions
you need answers to your question so
don't be afraid to ask them okay
to answer this question let me work
through how companies typically raise
money and hopefully get the answer in
the video at the beginning when a
company started it started by one person
or a couple people you guys own all the
shares right if it's one founder you own
100 of the shares if you're in a
partnership you may own 50 of the shares
or 33 and a third depending on how you
split it up with your partners as you
grow
a lot of these companies look for
funding you look for financing and
typically how you start is you go to an
angel investor so if you own 100 of your
company you go to an angel investor say
you give up 10 of your business okay you
give up 10 of your business you are
trading shares in your company for money
so they're paying you let's say a
hundred thousand dollars and you give up
ten percent of the shares so now they
own those shares you owe 90 they own 10.
as you keep growing typically you go
from angel investor to venture
capitalist a venture capitalist is not
one person but a group of angel
investors who've pulled their money
together or a company who wants to fund
new businesses and make some money doing
it and it's the same idea though as an
angel investor you are selling a part of
your company to
another company now who will own a piece
of your their own piece of your company
and in return they're giving you money a
lot of times the goal for vc for venture
capitals is to take you public
and going public selling your shares on
the new york stock exchange on the
nasdaq is very similar to selling shares
to an angel investor or to a venture
capitalist okay you are giving up a
percent of your business but not to one
person not to a company but to
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people any individual investor can go
and buy your share if your sure is 100
bucks i could put a hundred dollars into
your company i own one share of your
business so if you go public say you
give up half of your company okay you're
going public you still loan half your
shares
the other half are owned by
the masses
the reason why the shares are still
available is that people are buying and
selling them okay you may still hold on
to all your shares the angel may still
hold on to shares the vc vc typically
wants to get out so they'll they'll be
selling their shares and there's all
these people who own the shares but
there's people who want to buy it too
and so the stock price is determined by
people making that exchange they want to
buy the shares and you want to sell the
shares and it not may not be you
specifically in the business but any
shareholder right if i buy google
and it doubles in price i might be
thinking hey i want to get out of google
i want to make some cash so i'm now
willing to sell my shares and other
people willing to buy so there are no
new shares being made right there's no
new shares you're not saying hey i'm
adding a million new shares to the
market that sometimes does happen but
it's it's rare there's no new shares
that we're creating here it's just the
ones that are already outstanding the
ones that are already out there are
being bought and sold so let me give you
another example say you wanted to buy so
you want to buy a 2005 honda civic okay
you wanted to buy an 05 honda civic for
whatever reason
there are no new 05 honda civics being
made there are none that are new ones
being made because it's at 05 honda
civic but you can go and buy one because
somebody who has that 05 honda civic is
willing to sell it you have to come to a
price you know if you offer them 100
bucks they may not take it you offer
them five grand maybe they'll take it
right so you have to set the price but
there's somebody willing to sell it it's
the same thing happens with your with
your shares with the stock prices right
there are no new shares being made
but the ones that are out there are
being bought and sold depending on what
the price is
now in the rare circumstances some
companies will also buy back their
stocks so there's fewer shares on the
market or in some extreme cases they'll
go private so an example is mary kay ash
she had mary kay cosmetics she launched
her company she grew it to big success
she raised public money she took it
public she put on the stock exchange she
got a boatload of cash from it she used
it to expand her business she didn't
like the direction that it was going and
having to p shareholders so she bought
back all the shares back from them and
then she owned the whole company again
and then in that case there are no more
shares because she owns them all and she
doesn't want to give them up
but usually there's a certain percentage
of the shares that are owned by the
general public owned by individual
investors and they're always willing to
sell it if it's at the right price and
so that's what the stock market
facilitates is people buying and selling
shares of existing companies when they
can agree on the price so hopefully that
helped answer your question not a stupid
question if you have more let me know
what they are i'll do my best to answer
them for you if you guys like this video
thumbs up below let me know what you
think leave a comment underneath ask me
a question make a video reply and you
want to see more videos like this click
on my face subscribe to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon
you